yo hey
all right we're cooking we're cooking
we're back baby
good to be back it's been a whole week
has passed and i feel like a ton of [ __ ]
has happened
yeah it's a lot we're not i mean we're
now available on parlor youtube
and uh i think we're doing a live from
the capitol next week
that place is wide open what uh so you
just got back from
phoenix how was that uh boy are my arms
tired no it was great great club i mean
you hate to say it but all these all
these gun-toting towns are just living
life
they are the sun is shining people are
out
the bars are open very careful i i i you
know i didn't really mingle with anybody
but
boy oh boy great club great people great
town
i always say every guy there looks like
an out of work ufc fighter and every
girl looks like an ex-porn star
it's sacramento too right every dude i'm
like is that chuck liddell
again exactly it's bad tattoos
it's like weird haircuts where the sides
are shaped but the top is heavy
and utah is like that as well yeah utah
underrated salt lake beautiful uh i
can't wait to get back to phoenix man i
really can't uh it's funny
you just said uh the boy or my arms
tired we got some [ __ ]
for our last episode because we left
rodney dangerfield
off uh the one-liner comics the best one
liner comics
and we just [ __ ] and you just quote
honey young man like that's another one
right that's the grandfather he's the
king yeah he's the original oh jeez how
do we leave out rodney
take my wife please though is like the
ultimate that's like the first
great one-liner that i know of killer i
mean he had a million of them uh i went
to a uh
i went to a hockey game no i went to a
boxing match and a hockey game broke out
he's got some great ones like way ahead
of his time see rodney's tough because i
don't even see him as a one-liner i just
see him as this brilliant legendary
killer comic i don't even think of him
as like a genre
yeah henry youngman won uh mancy's a
doctor tells him he's got six weeks to
live
says he's got no money he gives him
another six weeks
that's classic comedy i love it yeah
dangerfield too man like
so many [ __ ] classic those carson
sets
are just oh dude what's great about
dangerfield everybody always says comedy
doesn't hold up it doesn't last comedy's
got an expiration date
his [ __ ] holds up for 3 000 millennia
it's got millions of views it kills with
the young and old
dude i'll tell
my mother she never breastfed me she
told me she liked me as a friend all
right
those are like perfect lines that was an
ugly kid i'll tell you i love it
oh it's genius i mean uh i saw a guy
jogging naked in my neighborhood i said
what are you doing he said well i said
why are you doing that he said you came
home early
oh it's [ __ ] gold my wife called me
said hey come over nobody's home i went
over there there was nobody home
[Laughter]
yes my wife my wife she wants to have
sex in the car and she wants me to drive
come on i went to the bartender i said
surprise me
show me a naked picture of my wife
the only problem with rodney is he's
given hope to every tom dick and loser
who goes that you know rodney didn't
make it till he was 57 so i still have a
shot like nah you got no shot
but rodney opened the door for all that
that that same sentence hey ronnie
didn't make it till 57.
yeah yeah man but that's what we need
less of right now hope
uh anyway sorry that was number one
no no you're what i'm with louis black
and rodney are the two that everyone
brings up
right right you ever uh
you ever uh your buddy's the third
how about phoenix though is like that's
a party that's a you've been there how
many times you've been there
i've probably been there four times it's
a party town the people are
in great shape and i realize i think
it's because it's hot all year round you
can't
put on weight there because you'll just
sweat your ass off everybody's in shorts
and flip-flops and you know sleeveless
all the girls are in yoga pants it's
it's bananas and everybody's nice
i think because you don't know who's got
a gun ooh that's a good point
aha i have a point yeah it's just like
why is this guy so nice to me
when i'm driving my rental car he
doesn't know if i got a glock under the
seat
that's a good point so you know i'm not
a gun guy but they keep you in line i
think
that's like people in new york are such
rude [ __ ] like that guy doesn't have
a gun
no guns we're not allowed here that's
good that's a good point
in new york a new a car cuts you off you
give them one of these
right i think he's got a gun exactly no
one's flicking off traffic
you know in an intersection phoenix
that's a good point no no sir i mean you
never know who's got a rifle or whatever
it's uh it keeps you in line you know
you don't want to die
it's like the old it's like the uh the
[ __ ] andrew jackson days
right oh dude joe zimmerman's andrew
jackson joke
if you ever heard it google zimmerman on
andrew jackson
all the crazy [ __ ] that president did
man give it a goog like the amount of
people he shot the amount of
just people he shot in the face on the
like the lawn of the white house
just in a duel that's when presidents
didn't have their [ __ ] henchmen do
their bidding that's when they're like
i got this yeah the good old days
it's funny how back then i think a
president had to be like a tough badass
that was the only way you got high now
it's like is this guy sensible
is he a family man or a smart person
back then it was like
will he shoot this stranger oh yeah
first president general washington
i mean bad [ __ ] yeah wooden
teeth
smoked weed owned slaves it was a
different time
i liked him like badass like he owned
slaves i'm like
well i think back then if you didn't own
a slave it was weird like look at this
[ __ ]
like you're not eating meat now yeah
yeah exactly
if you didn't own slate you're vegan
what about um
hmm i'm thinking of what presents a
woman was was taft a badass
didn't he die in a pretty who's the
president who died like immediately in
the office or someone who died
yeah he died in a tub or he got stuck in
the tub but then like
teddy roosevelt was shot during a speech
and finished the speech
which is for a comic i'm like i get
heckled one guy yells you suck i
i cancel the show you know this guy's
getting shot in the shoulder
it's amazing when you think of like the
[ __ ] people accomplish and then i'm just
like
i i fought to get to my bodega for an
egg sandwich at like 1 45
today exactly i was like i was like
[ __ ] like let me put some [ __ ] let
me put
the rocky theme on i'm like i made i was
like i missed i missed it by five
minutes
they cut out right 1 30. and publicists
were weirder
were different back then like now it's
like uh trump said [ __ ] and a tweet so
we gotta like
scrub that from the internet so he
doesn't get a bunch of hate but back in
the day
what's the guy uh oh is it truman
oh i'm an idiot the guy who couldn't
walk
polio was it fdr yeah
yeah maybe it was him he had to fake
being able to walk so they would put
like
stirrups and metallic beams in his pants
so he could kind of
shuffle around for the camera like like
like when you use peanut butter and a
dog for like an animated thing yeah
yeah yeah exactly but it's like look who
cares like we don't need this guy
jogging but back then you had it
you need your image an image of a strong
presence yeah
he's getting wheeled around like my legs
are hanging on
they're not completely dead what uh what
are you drinking
oh good question good question well
i stayed out all night drinking last
night and i had like the 8 a.m flight
and then the flight's five and a half
hours from phoenix so
i'm like running on fumes i took a nap
so i figured
i need a little jolt and we're having a
cocktail
so we're going to do a hold on i got a
big cup of cup of coffee
and then a friend of mine jamie lynn was
nice enough to give me a
she's a booze distributor so i tried she
came to my show the other night
tall good looking puerto rican jew yeah
she
by the way she she said she was going to
send me one of those bottles jamie lynn
if you're watching i'd love one
uh so you're doing are you doing an
irish coffee right now is that yours
yes sir this is a first an irish coffee
on our show
i know right uh i never really drink
these i'm a bloody mary guy
[ __ ] it yeah if you're if you're if
you're forced to go to like a brunch or
something
you're bloody mary over mimosa all day
right oh yeah well i'm a heterosexual
male here i mean i can't
i can't hold that little flute might as
well be a skin flute
i'm also not big on making already
weak drinks weaker right right a good
point
yeah i know bloody mary it's got the
sodium it's got the okra and the pickle
and the onion
the celery and i like tomato juice so
bm all day great man i love like an old
episode of mad men
when they're in the meeting and they've
got those little uh those little glass
uh carafes yeah of like they've got the
mimosa they've got the
bloody mary like that's a [ __ ]
business meeting that's how you do
business man
i know man that some lady back then with
like a
miniskirt had to fill that tomato juice
carafe for the boss to come in that's
insane
different time yeah and then she got
filled by the boss it was a very
different time
she was bloody mary later all right
i went too far and nah there is no too
far on on
one this is the bar i'm doing a glass of
wine and i've been doing brown liquor
tequila every week i'm doing a very
funky glass of wine dude i'm doing
natural wine
so this is natural it's right it's
[ __ ] orange dude look at that
yeah it looks like eight uh apple juice
it's dude it's delicious it's funky it's
weird
it's uh this is the bottle right here
oh so now is this considered a white i
guess it's white grapes but it's like
i'm not a big white guy but the orange
is pretty damn good man
i'm not a big white wine guy i kind of
always remember that show bored to death
would be on with jason
schwartzman i used to love that show i
liked it but i didn't love that he was a
white wine guy
uh see i like a white wine on a hot day
you know growing up in new orleans white
wine
it was like there at the table was like
a table wine the red was too thick the
teeth turned blue or
purple the tongue gets thick i don't
know this is where you show your
southern roots and i show my new york
roots because i'm like i like a
full-bodied red wine in the winter
there's something nice about it
it looks like a bourbon or a red wine in
the winter for sure
yeah that's see that sounds nice wine is
like weed to me red wine is like weed
where i see a guy hitting it and i'm
like damn that looks good then i do it
i'm like ah this is too much
but i get it you know it goes great with
food it's just it's too heavy for me
it's too
it's too coaty it coats my my mouth
which i guess is what people like it
does do that but like red wine and pasta
man that's what it's all about
let's see that's that's what everybody
tells me it sounds here as well
but i don't know i just it's too it's
too thick and i want to like it you know
just the greeks and chugging wine and
you know
i see these old photos of the castle but
yeah
they had a whole god of wine dionysus
the god of wine
that's true wow what a bunch of booze
bags yeah it's weird that that's your
your whole thing though it's like you
know zeus is like throwing lightning
bolts at people
you know yeah there's people just got a
music
got a beauty and then yeah and then he's
like i just i just get shit-faced and
they're like
[Laughter]
right probably the most fun god
probably hades might be fun though ah
hades yeah he seems cool
although hermes hermes what a lame god
uh he's like a ups guy he's like he's
like an executive assistant he's a
[ __ ]
god yeah exactly cupid never got it
cupid valentine's day what a dumb
[ __ ]
holiday it [ __ ] dudes in the ass
it kills us like it's so much pressure
you got to make the girl happy you got
to spend a ton of money it's got to be
the right
thought put into it you can't get her
you need two gifts too flowers aren't
enough anymore it needs to be like
it needs to be like the nice big gift
and then like
the dumb thoughtful gift right right
that little one that's like
i care i put thought into this yes
i got i hate that [ __ ] and then you
gotta throw the dinner on top so you
gotta have flowers you gotta get the
gift and then we gotta go out to dinner
you don't even get points for the
flowers anymore by the way now
cause flowers are an obvious one
father's like yep of course you're
getting me flowers that's
right it's like a kid getting candy on
it it's like kids getting candy in
halloween now they want more
right right i want a gift card [ __ ]
yeah
you're eight get out of here i i that
was a bad analogy i feel like kids are
fine with candy i feel like i missed the
mark on that analogy
i don't know i could see you want a cool
costume you know that's the point i was
making
you know yeah i get it i get it but no
you're right flowers is default now it
has to be done it's just understood
where i mean michael che had that great
joke like he's like i get you a gift and
you blow me on valentine's
day you should be blowing me on tuesday
you know like why is this a gift now
this is like part of the deal we're
dating
damn right yeah he's that's old too
that's like a 10 year old joke
he's got a few we were just like ah [ __ ]
you
i know i know i just signed an old
picture with three of us
like the seller one night it was it's a
classic man we
damn where did these [ __ ] days go ah
i had that picture framed i know that we
were
at the vu yeah damn
man and jay speaking of one more drink i
don't i don't want to out the guy but
nobody could booze like jay back in the
day like those caroline's nights where
you got an
open bar oh my god he would get smushed
i thought we could drink and then we'd
be like oh yeah he's a [ __ ]
heavyweight that guy
have you and you never really saw him
puking or stumbling like
you know i've seen you walk down
broadway i gotta tackle you before the
the horse and buggy hits you same with
me i'm wet in the bed remember that time
you cured me after that uh oh yeah party
i think i like [ __ ] threw you over a
shoulder and threw you in a cab
i was like i'm not letting this [ __ ]
guy go anyway i i woke up in your
apartment i've never been there you had
a female roommate i didn't know what was
going on you made me a kale smoothie
i'll never forget it i was just trying
to bring you back to life man put some
good nutrients in the in the bod
yeah that was a tough morning i couldn't
walk i was like fdr
i couldn't get out of bed he gave me the
smoothie we went and got pizza we
watched
eastbound and down i gave you some beans
so you could make it look like you'd
walk
and uh eastbound it down dude is there a
better hangover show
no that i was not into it i never heard
of it you showed it to me
that danny mcbride mcbride he's the best
so good i mean he's he's kind of a bill
murray where he's doing the same guy
every movie and you're fine with it
yes yeah he's uh he's so [ __ ] funny
it's like it's like he's a dude that
you're like i don't care if it's not
a good movie i still won't i'll still
watch it if he's in it
totally totally and he's got the cool
backstory i think he might he made that
movie uh
fifth way flip this way yeah
it's completely insane he's just the
same guy he's just
uh kenny powers but he's like a shitty
taekwondo instructor
exactly exactly like adam mckay saw it
and will ferrell loved it and then they
scooped him up and that i love [ __ ] like
that like swingers you know favreau
and vince vaughn they're just skinny
punks trying to make it you know dude i
got a fabric story i
i love swingers first off like i had the
poster on my wall as a kid don't have it
started like
i mean i know they're not supposed to be
cool but i was a little kid i thought
they were cool man
i know they're making fun of themselves
and like vince vaughn was like a hot
dude you're like oh he's like so cool
and uh basically i'm doing a show it's a
good michael chase story
we're opening for kevin neal and
caroline's many years ago i just told
this story in doug loves movies but it's
short anyway
and that's one weekend oh dude shay was
the most fun guy to do those weekends
with because he would drink and he's
low-key he's like he just kind of he's
like
just kind of pops in and we'll be like
downing drinks with you all night it's
great yeah but
uh we both are kind of killing all
weekend until sunday it's a light crowd
they're kind of stiff we're not doing
that hot
and it's like whatever i'm like [ __ ]
that's john favreau in the crowd i love
swingers this sucks
and then he comes back to the green room
to chill with kevin neil is a great guy
yeah he's like such kevin nealon is like
super nice like
i remember he's like watching my set
giving me tags
uh great guy i hit a i had a bit i was
just like
trying out what i was saying like how
was it i remember this joke and he gave
me this is like kevin neil's mind is how
funny i think he is but uh
i'm doing a bit uh well i'm like as a
young
like how like when you're a kid you're
walking around the street with a joint
in your mouth like
[ __ ] the police and now i'm like at that
age where i'm like where the [ __ ] are
the police you know
everything happens and then uh his time
his tag was something like uh you hear
you hear uh machine guns and you're like
oh it's just part of the song you know
i'm like that's [ __ ] like he'd give
him tags i'm like oh these are like he's
got a weird clever mind
but yeah anyway we're we're in the green
room and
um jay is like let's take a picture all
of us and i could tell like favre was
like [ __ ] these guys i don't want to
take a picture i'm
just catching up with my friend i just
watch these idiots bomb probably
and yeah and he's like uh okay and jay
like grabs them all in and
i'm just like laughing i'm like this is
awful you know it's like not how i want
to meet john favreau
sure and uh take the picture and then
i'm like well that was [ __ ] weird
anyway five days later este at the
comedy cellar is like
can you do an a15 tonight someone
probably norden or colin quinn dropped
out
i go by who's in the front row [ __ ]
john favreau
whoa i just watched him hate me again
i watched him dislike my set twice in
one week
oh man well the joke's on him because
you got
into the joker he has nothing to do with
the joker
i know but i can see him going this
guy's going nowhere he's a hack he's
doing the same act i saw him twice
one night i hate him he's going nowhere
then boom you're in a [ __ ]
tom phillips movie and he makes the
mandalorian so
[Laughter]
iron man i know i know he's like a
[ __ ]
beast he was famous then but now he's
like
taste maker famous like he can he's
directing movies he's doing all kinds of
[ __ ]
and his episode of the sopranos is like
the funniest
oh yeah wow i forgot about that it's one
of the funniest episodes
also you know he's made it when he did
that he did that movie chef
which was not great i think it's
overrated but
his wife in the movie is kat now what's
her name
what's the chick from modern family the
colombian
fear vergara his wife is sophia gregara
and his ex
is scarlett johansson i'm like what all
right this guy this is so unrealistic
this fat
loser chef queef he's got the two
hottest woman in hollywood as an ex-wife
and current wife
i'm like all right you're two it you're
two you're too big now
fat dudes had a run where their ego like
the whole kevin james thing where you're
like right you're like
it it is weird when it's like became a
thing where like the fat dude just
always had the hottest wife so i mean
dad bod was like
a huge phenomenon women were like i like
a dad but what can i say and
like all these fat guys are just cashing
in that ain't a dad bod that's a [ __ ]
uncle bod
that's nice
i hate dad that's so [ __ ] when they
were like jason momoa's dad
bought him like [ __ ] all of you he's
ripped he's ripped that's his
thing yeah come on you know what else i
hate and
i get it but i'm a [ __ ] when they go
nice dad joke i'm like look i get what
you're saying but
you know who's a dad louis ck chris rock
dave chappelle bill burr like
these are fathers it's a bit of a leap
to just say it's a dad joke
i get it but i don't know there's a lot
of funny dads out there who the hell's
saying that
i get that all the time i mean i like to
tweet dumb puns and dumb
little jokes and singers twitter's like
your garbage can you're just like
throwing you're just like
these are like jokes i wouldn't tell a
lot of sometimes the premise you tell on
stage but you know
right you're right it's condescending
yeah then there's this dad rock and
there's i guess there's mom jeans
yeah goes both joke
that's true i don't think so huh
interesting but yeah favreau wow that's
fun that you uh you died in front of
brutal one of the hollywood elites oh
man brutal it's like one of the things i
forgot about
and they were talking about him on
douglas movies no it's like you know
when you just have those that you're
like [ __ ] flashback
early comedy yeah oh yeah speaking of
those crazy caroline's booze nights
the carolines was so cool because we
were young comics and we were doing [ __ ]
bar rooms and whatever club we'd get our
hands on
but if a big headliner came to
caroline's they would trust us
to bring the heat and have jokes so you
got to do like a 350 seater in the
middle of midtown
it was the highlight of your life for
the whole weekend to make like 500 bucks
in the city
yeah so you you got the the cream of the
crop
best gig ever jim jeffries weekend
we all [ __ ] blood we're like holy hell i
said i i know the opener
what was it 10 years ago probably 10
years ago yeah and
i was like i know sam well he's a booze
bag
i want to get sloppy i'm a huge fan of
jim jeffries
i'm hanging out there all weekend we
went out i mean jay was there uh
green bomb was getting trashed by uh
jefferies the whole weekend called him a
homo and everything uh
that's what yeah shea was on that show
too yeah that was crazy that was it
also me and shane i guess they paired me
with chad a lot but it was always fun
um oh dude i remember going out to the
molly we no not the mollyweed what's
that red bar
right across the street not uh not the
playwright
yeah playwright playwright and uh i
would be drinking like a whiskey and
soda and he would just do the thing
where he tipped it
like keep going [ __ ] you know drink
more you're like
i'm gonna die but that's that's who he
was i remember one night we musta had
like he went
so hard well first off i invited her in
my family's thanksgiving that year
what yeah because he was like i was like
i bet he's got nowhere to go for
thanksgiving
and i was like maybe we should come and
uh he was too hungover he couldn't make
it
yeah but i was also the best
[Laughter]
i got an anecdote for you people so i'm
[ __ ] a thai hooker in the ass right
my mom oh dear uh
yeah no it was probably for the best but
uh
i mean my parents have seen jim's act
and they think he's hilarious you know
so i mean he is
he he does kind of transcend yeah you
know and he
because he's so smart i mean
his gun bit's the best bit of the last
20 years man it's it's unbelievable bit
yeah he's
he's crass but it's still smart and
it's fun and anybody get on board and
he's quick too if he gets heckled he's a
[ __ ] killer
yeah he's he's a kill i mean i remember
that weekend i still remember lines from
it where he said this is someone in the
crowd you're gonna wake up tomorrow
morning and you're gonna think i was a
bit of a [ __ ]
and that's the only time you're right
yeah he was fun every comic had that
crazy wild that was back
i hate to reminisce like a douche but
that was like there was no political
[ __ ] there was no like
everybody trying to cancel or anything
it was just like jokes
funny boozy weekends we were also so
much younger i mean it was yeah just
about like i think we didn't even i i
think twitter was less of a thing at the
time yeah
twitter was more a place to like be like
let me try like a [ __ ] up joke on
twitter and it wasn't like it now it's
like
people just pander and that's what they
get their likes like look at what
happened you're like oh my god
and some look there's a and it is good
sometimes but it's not good for comedy
no it's good for news sometimes so they
can spread news but it's not just
a joke no no and it just keeps getting
meaner and meaner and people are looking
for ways to be like that joke sucked
you're like i know that's why i put it
on here you douche get out of here
but yeah it's uh those were fun times
and
i'm glad we we lived it up too who did
you remember
who do you open for there that was like
a hot weekend do you remember
oh geez uh jb's move was unbelievable
oh yeah i mean was he a fun hang
not a not too much of a hang because he
was getting so famous that he was in and
out but like
you know he's got full leather suits on
he's got these
crazy glasses at one point i went he was
killing and i left to go get a beer i
came back and he was climbing
the diamonds i was like this is a hell
of a show
also fun about him like it was right
when curb was curved like curb was new
and hot he was on curb
and you look out in the crowd i'm
opening it's all jews
it's like yarmulkes as far as the eye
can see
and even when i bring him up they go
the place goes nuts he comes out within
six minutes half the room was
empty because he was so filthy wow
that's hilarious so they wanted leon but
they got jb
yeah and leon's dirty but jb is like
filth dumpster-fired gross you know
coming my eye your [ __ ] is bleeding
whatever it is
and that you can see these uh the
leibowitz's and the
and the bombs like all right we gotta we
gotta we gotta get that lirr back
it may as well have been a bar mitzvah
yeah it really he really
he is a dirty guy but he's so funny i
mean like so funny
yeah he i remember i saw him one morning
it's he's got such a nice energy about
him
we used to have the same manager and he
uh so he was always friendly and stuff
but then i remember
doing morning radio in baltimore one
morning and just being like a mess and
he comes out and just goes like hey
and i was like oh [ __ ] like that energy
is just so
it's so nice he just he has like a real
showbiz energy but like a positive you
know
totally totally yeah he's a good egg and
he was like one of us just a struggling
guy
kind of doing gigs here and there and
then he got
curve and it all changed yeah it's crazy
because he's in a lot of movies too but
i guess
uh yeah curb was huge for him oh yeah
recurring good money hbo finally got
some exposure because i think he was on
like
there's always that urban circuit where
like i did bts this and comic view that
but it's
it's not really enough to propel you
into theaters or anything
yeah it's always you need so much to be
like because we just want to be comics
we just want to be stand-ups but you got
to do so many [ __ ] things now
i know and you just think yeah it's the
worst
but you know [ __ ] i mean it gave us an
excuse to do this this is kind of fun
you know
this is great but like how many chad
daniels are out there or anthony devitos
or guys where you're like man you should
be huge
or you should be at least selling out
yeah
you know you're right and if if you
don't know who those guys are chad
daniels anthony devito
look them up youtube yeah buy their
albums
spots yeah killers buy tickets
it's comedy central with him though it's
like you know
how many specials did he give to comedy
central and
three they buried him man i mean
it's like it's like it's weird where i'm
like i'm negotiating with them i'm like
can i just please be seen somewhere
i know i know then you're like maybe
i'll put it on my youtube and they're
like kill yourself we'll sue you you're
like
all right i thought you might want to
get some eyeballs on this but
whatever it's a model it's like we're
going against i mean i remember when i
was like negotiating because we did
similar things where
amy schumer produced both of ours and
uh you know i remember negotiating to
get it online and they were like it'll
be on amazon i was like beautiful amazon
everyone has amazon i can at least
direct people there
and then it wasn't on amazon i guess
their deal with amazon fell through and
then i was like well it's gotta be on
the
it's gonna it'll be on the website and
they're like yeah it'll be on the
website there's an ad every three
minutes
on and these are like these are like i
don't know where these commercials come
from these are like three minute breaks
it's kill it it kills it kills any
momentum and it's like yeah
mine was on the app whatever that means
so like you got to sign up for this app
and i'm directing i'm trying to like
help fans out you know via dm like oh
you got to go here put your name in
they're going to send you a code to your
phone then you put the code in and i'm
like
i don't even want to do this it's my
special i'm like with my parents they're
like turn it on i'm like i can't figure
it out we just said [ __ ] it
we went to [ __ ] ruby tuesday we
couldn't handle it it was too much
that's uh no it's it's brutal man it
really it's a bummer because
we were like we got the money but we
were like sacrificial lambs for this
experiment with their app and it didn't
work so
yeah you know that's what it is but it's
bittersweet you know because
you got these like a guy like chris
stefano [ __ ] hilarious
great guy he did an hour with them who
knows if anybody saw it
i hope they did but now he's just
running around making his own [ __ ]
and cleaning up so yeah and look i also
love so many of the people comedy
central that's the other thing it's like
they were
handcuffed by a shitty corporation in
viacom i mean that's really what it was
is that roy wood
brilliant i mean brilliant but when when
your model is out of date
like imagine telling people like hey
watch my thing at 11
pm now like everyone would be like go
[ __ ] yourself
exactly we knew that was added at a
place in time years ago we knew that
but i mean it's funny like i'm sure you
get this when you go on stage i did a
show and they were like you know
no one there knew me whatever was you
know and they were like he's got a uh
he's got a new youtube special and it
got a laugh and i was like oh
no well it's just like some of the
public if they're not comedy savvy they
don't know that that's a thing that
people do
of course of course and it's like no
we're doing this for
longevity and for eyeballs and for the
long game we're not
like we could maybe sell it somewhere
but no one will ever
like you want to sell it to epics go
ahead you know right
right exactly might as well sell it to
hallmark or stars
or oxygen special my new special is
actually in the oprah network
well i think you're right i think
youtube is the future i think youtube is
where podcasts were 10 years ago where
like
imagine 10 years ago you went on stage
and said hey this next guy's got a
podcast he'd be like who gives a [ __ ]
what does that mean has he been on
tonight's show
youtube was a punchline is what i'm
saying like youtube like people used to
say
you could see his next special on
youtube and i'm like that's the [ __ ]
way dude
totally i mean tell that to some
unboxing kid
from asia who makes 10 million dollars a
week opening packages with his mom
in his pajamas the kid's [ __ ] he's
bigger than bezos
he's getting his dick sucked by other 10
year olds he's like i'm [ __ ] i'm a
rock star
yeah yeah he unflaps that back pajama
thing he's getting his ass eaten by some
kid you know
yeah those kids have got it made all
those youtube stars are killing it
what uh so tell me was phoenix do you uh
what give me phoenix stories i know
you've had some phoenix stories
oh dude man i mean i've had some wild
nights in phoenix
uh that's a [ __ ] destin that's a
crazy road gig
oh man scottsdale we got to talk about
scottsdale which is like a phoenix
suburb basically it's all
it's all dentist wives and they driving
golf carts and everybody's got fake
white teeth
and you know hair pieces and polo shirts
everybody plays golf
and i mean i this is i don't know seven
years ago i ran i ran through like a
series of
milfs in uh scottsdale it was
unbelievable
i was like a pool boy for a weekend
and uh and it was all one week it was
the same
what were you doing the apps or was that
for the show or what no i think it was
pre-apps it was after the show and like
there's so many
beautiful women in that area that i
think they're not as entitled
so they're like hey this uh mediocre
comedian is talking to me that's pretty
good
um yeah my husband won't talk to me
that club stand up scottsdale for those
of you listening i mean first off
the club was on bar rescue twice
and it was not rescued it was still
[ __ ]
it was not rescued it was a hilarious
episode i mean
so yeah it's got problems i remember i
watched the reunion episode where they
like bring it back that says to see how
it's doing
yeah our man howard hughes who ran it
first off great guy but
you know there were some issues uh first
off
you know he would go up and do like 30
minutes and you're just like [ __ ]
all right come on howard like i know you
aren't in the right place but he'd be
like you guys aren't drinking enough and
i'd be like oh i gotta follow this all
right
like it's a two-drink minimum and i'd be
like you don't
just have the manager tell you don't say
that on stage
right right he was an eccentric to say
the least he had big
coke rim glasses and he was on coke and
he would do a shady kind of slimy uh
club owner thing where
there was like six open mic or seven
open micro sitting in the back of the
club
and he would go you and
you and they'd be like yes and they each
did five minutes for free
so four kids thought they were getting a
like a good slot or a good deal or a
paid gig and they got five minutes for
free
that's hilarious yeah he would uh i
remember on the bar rescue redemption
episode
he john taffer was like this man was a
marine
he goes i don't want to humiliate him i
respect what he did for our country and
there's a whole crowd
and howard gets in his face and it's
like about to get ugly and you see one
of the managers in the crowd
she stands up and goes howard no and
that's they kept reusing that one line
what what was she saying that no like
don't start [ __ ] with john taffer
like oh howard no
that's great it was terrible but anyway
i got a howard hughes story oh daddy
i did that so first off this is so i did
the club the first time this is when it
was in the bar rescue place so i guess
it was like a really cool looking
place yeah remember that that room was
beautiful i thought it was a great room
um anyway for comedy i go back
and this is the time i go back no one
tells me that it's changed
venues so i just land he picks me up and
he's like all right man uh
so here's the i was like oh it's a new
hotel he's like yeah that's the club too
so it's like
oh okay it's a new club i'm like it's
like a looks like a mexican restaurant
he's like yeah that's what it is
yeah i was like all right well whatever
i mean i'm here i guess so i'm there
everything about it's a mess like
uh he was like he had this amazing
girlfriend she was like so cool and she
was like
she was like what you were saying she's
like a hot yogi and so nice and uh yep
i remember he would just be like i'd be
like all right dude like someone's
acting out in there can you just like
help out and he was just like
my girlfriend's really mad at me i
blacked out last night i got to get out
of here
you're the [ __ ] you're running the
club come on wow you
jump ship so anyway i'm doing the show
and it's like howard on stage whatever i
go up
and i i'm doing well i'm like all right
i'm doing pretty well it's good
some guy knocks his drink over and i'm
like i guess i'm killing pretty hard
and i'm just like
i'm like i am right i see it like this
woman's like he's having a stroke
and i'm just like oh my god
so all right stop the show uh
stop i have to get off stage we have to
call an ambulance i'm like howard call
an ambulance from the stage
he calls an ambulance then he comes in
and obviously i'm like the show's over
i'm not yeah the guy is a stroke
so he's like being a good sport about it
he's an older guy and howard comes in
first he starts doing schtick howard
gets on stage
like so he's like don't worry i've had a
stroke so how is it a stroke too we find
out
by the way it's yeah it's from uh coke
and red bull
that's what it wasn't like it wasn't a
joke where you're like poor guy i was
like no you brought on yourself
yeah yeah but he's riffing and the guy's
not answering and
i'm just like let him [ __ ] have a
stroke
yeah don't do your tight stroke chunk on
this guy
like let him i don't what is a stroke
exactly is it do you shake
do you seizure what does that look like
it looked like a bit i think it's
a lot of like i think it has to do with
like blood clots or something
yeah but uh yeah no it looked like he
was shaking it wasn't a seizure
uh i think you can lose feeling on side
to your face or
stuff like that yeah i mean look we've
seen it with people we know where like
they lose feeling in their arm
it's right yeah it's [ __ ] bad yeah
when the blood supply the part of your
brain is interrupted or reduced
preventing brain tissue from getting
oxygen and nutrients all right yeah
yeah so i guess i could slur speech and
hurt speech so how far into the set were
you
i was like 20. so anyway he keeps going
and finally the guy gets taken out in a
stretcher and like is such a
[ __ ] good dude he gives us like a
thumbs up and we're like
whatever so i'm like all right and it
seemed like he was gonna be okay it
seemed like he was speaking okay and
everything but
uh then
howard gets off and he's like are you
gonna go back up and i'm just like
i mean i guess he's i guess i should
people it's
fairly full i should probably go back on
so i gave it like 10 minutes just like
out of like
you know let's give this a minute and
then i went back on and just shat on
howard for like 20 minutes straight and
it was killing i was like this dumb
[ __ ] had a stroke here's how
the crowd's like applauding and he to
his credit was laughing his ass off in
the corner so i'm like
i mean he's a nut but it's like god we
need a lot of nuts
in this business that he is a well
meaning one i'll give him that
that's all we care about as long as
you're not malicious we don't mind a
psycho
or a weirdo as long as you're a nice
psycho
we don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah and uh he
could take a joke and
that's the i think he made the right
call there because you gotta go what
else could you do
well you gotta stop the show too but
then you gotta be like all right i mean
people bought tickets let's give them a
show but you
to give that guy a moment for [ __ ]
sake
but this is the only art form where
somebody has a stroke or a heart attack
or something horrible happens in the
crowd and you're going how can i make
this funny what's a good line here i
need a zinger here you know
if that happens in hamilton they go hey
oh stop the show you know they take the
wigs off for a second
do they i don't know i don't i i
wouldn't do it yeah
yeah and lane like john valjean like
first i stole bread now i have to watch
this [ __ ] everyone's applauded
i don't know right yeah man uh i don't
know what you do
it's it's that's happened twice happened
at the comic strip once
and a guy like collapsed who knows a
woman collapsed and they had to call an
ambulance and
chuck nice was on stage yeah i mean [ __ ]
happens you gotta you gotta
i mean when you do enough shows you're
gonna see some [ __ ] i mean that's never
happened to you
uh nothing like that i've never seen
i've seen fights break out i've seen
you know uh yeah i've seen like punches
thrown but never
uh never a stroke or a like an ambulance
thing that's [ __ ] crazy
it was [ __ ] weird it was that one was
like yeah i mean
this life man anyway uh give me a pet
peeve man
all right mine's weird yeah and i
i get really specific with my pet peeves
because uh
i don't know i get i get weirded out by
odd [ __ ] but um
i had this one i'm in phoenix i'm at a
bar with the opener
and great guy zoltan check him out oh
yeah he's funny he's really funny
you know him yeah yeah he's a san diego
guy right
san diego super cool super fun i i
requested him
i feel horrible saying this but they
they sent me two
openers they're like here watch these
videos i was like all right and
they were pretty rough and i was like
how about this guy they're like okay
fine
so i got them in i never had it's like
guess what we're gonna we're gonna bring
a good comic i hate when they give a
[ __ ] for
the like and i'm like hey get we're
doing this for the good of the show
i don't wanna exactly i wanna follow a
good comedian
yes the the crowd will like it the show
will do better why are you sending me
this [ __ ] puppeteer guy you know
so i just got him in there and he hadn't
done a show
indoors in like eight months so he was
all wacky but he pulled together he's
got some killer new stuff that got
rights
he's very he's a very respected guy in
the san diego scene as well like they
are like he's the
he's the dude you know oh yeah by the
way he's got a special
on youtube it has like two million views
which is pretty great for a guy with
like
you know not a lot of tv stuff so it's
the new way man
and uh yeah i think it's called modern
guy or something or modern man
modern male 1 modern yeah i think you're
right [ __ ] i shouldn't know that but
yeah remember i remember thinking i was
like is that is that
like a little nod to the iggy pop uh
i'm just a modern guy maybe
maybe he's a funky guy who knows yeah
uh all right so we go to this bar and
the bar had free pizza
and i was like oh [ __ ] look at this
freaky you know me if i see something
free i'm all over it
and i i jump on it and i'm like wow
what's this what's this about this is so
crazy
and one guy standing at the bar goes why
are you complaining just enjoy it
i'm like well i'm not complaining i'm
just saying like where
why what's the deal like this is pretty
great this is like eight boxes of pizza
with like loaded
pepperoni and sausage and veggies oh
this is
this is awesome what's this like a deal
they do every friday and he's like
stop questioning it just enjoy it i'm
not
i'm not bitching i'm curious and i
[ __ ]
lost it on this guy i'm like look why
can't i question maybe we can figure out
how we can get more if i ask how we got
it you know
so that that was my pet peeve i hate
that [ __ ] stop questioning no one's
questioning it i'm i'm
curious yeah curiosity not allowed
and that's how you get more that's how
you know it's like if you if you put
your tongue on this part of the labia
and your girlfriend goes crazy you're
like hey what was that so i can do it
again and she's not gonna be like
oh don't just enjoy the orgasm no i want
to figure it out
so i can get it again second half it was
you that enjoyed the orgasm
i'm trying to [ __ ] help you yeah yes
that's crazy
the the just just don't question it what
is this religion what do i have to do
yes
we can't just have some pizza i want to
know what happened to
i know i know exactly so he's like why
you complain i'm like i'm not
complaining you don't know what
complaining is
yeah so that's [ __ ] annoying i do
love the free pizza at a bar though i
remember like crocodile and alligator
lounge here in new york used to pull
that and it wasn't yes great pizza but
when you have a couple beers
how the [ __ ] can you tell the difference
honestly of course
that was a big date spot for a poor
comedian oh it was great
that's dinner and drinks in one shot
comics and we do shows there i mean it
was
right oh that was a great one yeah you
get a free pizza with every drink it was
like a personal pan pizza
when you're broke that's heaven it was
crazy and it was like
card it was like pretty shitty but it
was pretty good when you had a couple
drinks
ah dude isn't it crazy when we were in
our 20s what we consumed
i mean i'm surprised i wasn't just
miscarriaging every morning like
i would i would get drunk all night eat
halal and then go to bed
yeah i mean [ __ ] i think about like what
gives me diarrhea now
and i'm just like it's crazy i'm like
i'm like what did i have like
like something from like the dig in i
got like a healthy right
bowl or something and i'm just like oh
[ __ ] although i am
drinking still and i have a lot of
coffee let's face it we're not super
healthy mark
no you're right you're right but but
back then it was like yeah i'll take a
percocet
give me that bottle of whiskey and uh
hand me that lamb shank and it was all
gravy or diner we go to a diner all
night get a meatloaf you know
those the diner nights are the ones i
miss the most man when it'd be like
when it'd be like a tail would be like
we're going to we're going to the
whatever diner on you know in chelsea or
wherever
for him drunk mozzarella sticks
just the best man nothing better diners
are like what's hurting me
as much as anything right now because
like there's something about the hang
and the piece of a diner
yes yes you feel like you own the place
you know you're in there
it's you look around it's other
degenerates just like you
you're not really judged you can eat
fries apple pie
milkshake or eggs it's everything and
you got your guys with it it's a great
hang
i love it it's always open you get a
nice greek waiter being like what do you
like
and you're like yeah i [ __ ] like that
energy i like that i love it
love it you get a bowl of lucky charms
or the swordfish
whatever you want no one said i missed
that fish
no one's getting the swordfish but due
to coffee and like eggs
it's [ __ ] heaven late at night oh
yeah
yeah that's a i i'm with you on that pet
peeve i got one
it's that hit me a lot of people are
doing this now
and obviously suicide rates are much
higher depression is much higher is a
tough time
a lot of people are writing online
you're not alone
and i'm like guess what a lot of people
are alone right now that's not helpful
a lot of people physically i'm alone in
my apartment right now
so when people are not alone i'm like
i'm looking around and i'm alone
physically yes not only that good point
if i'm not alone that's actually
cautious or concern
if i if someone comes out of my closet
i'm like that's not [ __ ] helping my
mood
right right that's true yeah you're not
alone it's like no we are
online isn't it doesn't count as hanging
out
see i think a lot of people confuse
twitter with like i'm in a conversation
i'm hanging
we got a group going no that's not a
group
this is increasing our feelings of
isolation social media like it is linked
to every
sort of depression it's like yeah here's
how you know
they say never drink alone if you're
drinking on facebook with 5 000 friends
it's still alone
that still counts as drinking by
yourself
yeah they're not it's weird that we've
increased our amount
of friends on these like social media
platforms but we have like lesser true
friendships
yes very true very true friendships are
like
just being around a person like that's
why i think like i think
our friendship precedes this social
media boom
so maybe that's why we feel like we
could still do this and we're kind of in
the same room but yeah
when you think about it how many
friendships are like just dm'ing how are
you buddy it's [ __ ] like that you're
checking in your friends but like
we hung a lot coming up yeah exactly it
that the dm
[ __ ] it's nice but it's empty calories
it's not an actual relationship really
you know it's a bunch of acquaintances
which is cool but
yeah it's you know what it is we push
away from discomfort you know because
actually going to meet the guy at the
diner and then
maybe running out of things to say
having an awkward pause or his mom died
you got to hear about that for 20
minutes you know like
there's always there's always a little
bit of discomfort and with the dm it's
like
hey we're still friends i don't have to
do anything
i'm checking two boxes the discomfort is
different it's not like a discomfort
where there's an awkward silence it's a
discomfort where it's like
did they see that and not respond oh
yeah
exactly it's a different thing the
discomfort in real life we were like we
ever just see a movie
and and like people are talking like
they're like this is my brother and
we're best friends and we just kind of
and they're just like that's not how you
talk to your brother
yeah it's like when you talk to your
brother there's like awkward like i love
my brother i'm closing my brother but
like
there are like awkward silences it's
with family i think always for the most
part you know
sure that's part of part of being around
each other you know and
and back to your friends thing the
facebook
we have more friends but they're not
actual friends and i would say
everything is like that like
there's more activism but it's not
actual activism it's just tweeting
or it's or it's uh outrage but it's not
actual outrage they just want to be
perceived
as someone outraged so it's all pretty
phony i think
i'm just a digital girl in a digital
world man
exactly exactly it's you're right it's
all [ __ ]
because you know but then also then you
see the people that are going to some of
these things and you're like
well you don't want to be one of the
people that went to the capitol
that's true that's true yeah so
i mean like right i mean it's it's weird
like sometimes
going to things in person ain't always
better no
of course of course i mean some people
showed up to uh you know the
their job at the world trade center on 9
11. but
that's a bad example but hold on let me
think of something what was the dessert
oh
what about that fire in chicago the the
the white concert the white snake
i don't know oh what was that call in if
you know
god damn it it was a big concert and
everybody went and the doors got locked
and the place caught on fire and they
all died
damn yeah something in the 80s i can't
hold it
i hope it wasn't white snake i know
that'd be a hard way to go out
uh who was it white reaper i don't know
some band some 80s band and
everybody died it was like a big tragedy
damn yeah it's always when you read
about those things like the jonathan
landis thing remember the helicopter
no on his movie where i believe it was
jonathan landis
where people died in his helicopter
crash let me double check that real
quick what
yeah landis helicopter
uh yeah the twilight zone the twilight
zone
uh accident ground fatality three
aha so he did
get people killed i'm sure i don't think
this is his fault or
who knows i mean he's still working he
was found not guilty
oh it wasn't his movie that still got
away in your conscience
yeah totally yikes give that google on
the uh on the concert while you got it
pulled up just because now it's killing
me
somebody's screaming in in detroit
yelling at the screen right now
i see the who contra disaster no that
was a big
fire uh concert
concert fire door locked tragedy
a fire claimed the lives of a hundred
people doing the great white show
on great white that's it damn
great white there it is i knew it was
white something white supremacy
white power i knew it was one of those
but who are who's the great white
who were they it was just some like
heavy metal band i think
and uh i don't know maybe a couple
supremacists went down with the ship so
maybe it ain't so bad after all but
yeah the door got locked and they
couldn't get out and bill
[ __ ] went up in smoke damn
i love those stories though about like
like seth macfarlane was supposed to be
on the 911 plane but he got hung over
and didn't make it
amazing i heard him tell that story and
he said he like
had it had like a scotch as he like
watched it from the airport i think from
logan i mean can you [ __ ] imagine
that's a real eye-opener
maybe i don't know but yeah [ __ ] logan
logan yeah he was like
i think if you see that you're like all
right i gotta do something with my life
i gotta
that cartoon i've been thinking about
making i gotta make it he's on the phone
with fox he goes that dick joke
will be approved and like you can i just
survived 9 11 they're like all right put
it in
it's the ultimate bargaining chip you do
yeah i mean [ __ ] that is one of those
like that makes you kind of question
everything you're like that's the
ultimate what if
yeah because here's the crazy part is we
have those things in our life we just
don't know it
that was one day you were gonna go out
to a bar you said [ __ ] it i got diarrhea
and you stayed home and
you might have tripped on a curb or got
mugged or whatever the hell hit by a car
you never know
and we're trashing diarrhea but that
diarrhea might save our [ __ ] lives
dude
there you go good point that is crazy
that is crazy like you hear that about
flights a lot
like uh he was just i i think about that
constantly when i'm on a flight i'm like
is this the one
right i know because our odds have to be
going up because we fly
more than most so yeah but flights
anybody's gonna die it's us
but also then you've got to look at car
crashes too i think car crashes are like
they're more common than
flights but there's something about a
flight that it's so out of your control
and
car crashes are out of our control too
but you just for some reason you're so
high in the air that you're like there's
nothing i can do
i don't i always think when i'm like if
a car goes out of control i can like
spin out of there but i'm like who am i
john wick i'm not [ __ ] i'm not
spinning
yeah what are you john wick all of a
sudden
yeah i was thinking about that with some
of those dudes that like one of the guys
who died at the capitol they had that
like photos of him with like four guns
he had like the two
uh like aks and like the guns into his
waist and yeah died from like a heart
attack or something and it's like
you got to do some cardio you can't just
like
john wick wasn't a fat dude you know
yeah
he was uh he probably could run like two
miles on a treadmill if he had to
right right yeah by the way when are we
going to get our first fat
superhero that's a that's a good point
not a superhero but like
a action guy oh
i don't know does it negate the whole
things that's all it's all
active you know so could they could they
do it
does that send a bad message though that
kids with uh body issues could also save
the world
well i mean lizzo if if lizzo can do it
or
adele that's what adele lost all that
weight dude
i know and they yelled at her isn't that
funny that that's where we're at now she
loses weight they're like
you can't win there's no winning yeah
it's like all about bossy body
positivity until you don't look like me
then it's negative i take it back she
won
she's doing okay she's got a lot of
money in the bank she lost some weight
who gives a [ __ ] the point is when
someone gets that famous
people are gonna have their dumb
opinions on the super on the social
media when you're that big
a lot of those opinions are going to be
dumb the dumb ones are going to be
inflated
and there you go i mean she's got a
great life she's doing fine
yeah seinfeld because i get bummed out
about twitter sometimes and seinfeld
equates twitter
to stepping on an ant pile and the
[ __ ] answer is going crazy he's like
you're going to try to keep up with all
those ants they all have a different
path they're all going a different way
that's twitter
yeah yeah you can't keep up with it
that's a good point i mean
i'm gonna try to look less and less at
social media i i would like to
yeah yeah i've been been reading up
about stoicism i don't know where you
stand on that but uh
one of them is get off social media and
the other one is watch less news not
saying don't be informed but just
you don't need the crawl going every 10
seconds it's
it's cannot be good for your life no
no i mean the stimulus alone is more
than we're built to handle
you know what do they say technology is
growing faster than our intellect
and our evolution you know so we're
getting all this stimulus but our brain
is still
stuck in the 80s basically we've seen
some ugliness in the last
year that's going to be hard to shake
and i think psychologically for a lot of
people
it's hard to it's hard to like take in
where you're just like holy [ __ ] this is
like a lot
this is a lot like what happens in a
regular news week like
even if a lot of [ __ ] i mean look a lot
of [ __ ] happened in the 60s we weren't
alive for that but there's a lot of [ __ ]
happening
imagine if there was twitter in the 60s
and they'd be like
you know this is kennedy here's rfk
here's mlk and like
twitter's just going crazy he's [ __ ]
dead then there'd be like the edgy 60s
comedian like
here's my joke about jfk getting shot in
the face you know
i mean it would be exhausting you'd just
be like all right we get it you know
so ah dude i mean just just think about
the george floyd footage we saw that
like
from a foot away up close you could see
the sweat on his brow but then you see
you think in the 60s
it's like they're getting they're
shooting the black guys with the hose
the fire hose in la
and the dogs and it was like grainy
footage you saw two seconds of it then
it was moving on so like
yeah we take way more look at porn porn
is like
you know jizz in my ass and uh gaped me
and my fish hook my mouth i mean it's
and that's like is that a 13 year old
seeing that [ __ ]
okay that's just what i watch
porn is getting to i actually haven't
watched in a little while i'm trying to
stop watching
as much it's just too it's like i get to
a point where i'm like
this ain't gonna get better right right
let's
let's reel it in where it's at yeah porn
isn't going back a peg
no pun intended not only that but
neither is my imagination like if i'm
right here
and it goes fur like it's not gonna get
i'm not gonna be like if that's what's
making me come now
yeah it's not going to get more pg
exactly perfectly said so true
uh billboard has this funny bit about
how like these kids now see these porn
and like they're
they have the same visual memory as a
guy in the vice
squad you know just like it's too much
it's too dark
and this kid is too young to be
absorbing that [ __ ]
it's also hilarious you're just like
kids like i remember like when i was a
kid
like you know women were kind of like
they kind of like didn't know how to
blow you when you were a kid
right i kind of didn't know how to go
down on them and there was something
kind of innocent and charming about that
and now the kids are going to be like
spit on my dick they're like 13
you know yes that's true he's 13. he's
like stick a finger in my ass you're
like all right
right on it [ __ ] where do you go from
there
exactly it doesn't get my point is like
work your way up
yes here here i mean we got a long life
to live we're only living longer so uh
yeah yeah you don't need to be pegged at
11.
yeah but i'll say this
oh [ __ ] i had a point oh oh i got it
back
when is comedy gonna evolve because like
we're watching serial killer
documentaries
as entertainment like get the popcorn
ready ted bundy's coming on or
michael michael jackson's uh pedophile
thing is coming on like
high five here we go turn the lights out
it's like [ __ ] nick at night now
you know and but then comedy if you say
uh you know a joke about puerto ricans
people are still upset so you're like
how have we gotten so able to uh
withstand this
serial killer footage but still the
jokes are a problem oh i'll tell you why
it's pleased people like to stand in
their [ __ ] high chair and feel
uh better than and and that's what
you're doing with true crime you're like
all right well my life might be [ __ ]
up but i never murdered anybody
okay good point and they could also say
for women they're watching and they're
like well i just want to know how to
avoid this [ __ ]
you know right i'm sure some women are
watching you know some of these forensic
files you know like all right probably
shouldn't go camping with my current
boyfriend i don't know right so
right you look at that [ __ ] and you're
like all right well this i'm better than
that
and also you're kind of there's some
survivors like their survivor's guilt
when you survive
and someone else doesn't i think there's
like some form of like
well i survived and she did i'm better
than that person
i'm winning in some way i put myself in
better situations
and then you think about a joke and
they're doing the same thing with the
joke they don't like well they're like
well i didn't like that and i'm better
because i didn't make that [ __ ] joke
ah and also it's already
understood that ted bundy is an evil
monster with
us you walk out on stage people applaud
we're getting paid
we're saying horrible things people are
laughing so then they're like
wait how come we're we're approving this
but ted bunny at least we already know
he's a piece of [ __ ]
that's a great point and on top of that
we're watching this person we're
condemning them by watching them
yeah he's a [ __ ] monster he's a
people exactly so you watch him knowing
he's a monster and then you're almost
searching for humanity in a weird way
when you are
like let me find something about this
person
because in a weird way i think
psychologically it makes you make sense
of the world a little bit when
these monsters walk among us and i think
when you're watching entertainers slip
up
they're almost held on they're almost on
this pedestal where they're like okay
they
go out and perform they get to kill
their lives are almost
too good so rather than looking for
humanity you're looking for a flaw
oh nice
does that make sense i think you're
right i think you're right and
hopefully yeah you almost feel better
watching it there we go
putting down the orange yeah you feel
better watching it you're like look we
got this guy
[ __ ] him he's evil but could there be
something to be said for
i think we have it as much as we [ __ ]
and moan about america
and the world and all that it's not
perfect but
we're not dying of of uh famine we're or
you know your
your mom used to have four kids one
would just die that was kind of normal
one would freeze to death you know the
the crops aren't growing uh the
the native americans cut my head off we
got to go johnny's got to go to war he
never came back
we don't have that now we got ubereats
and only fans you know things are a
little better
so maybe we are seeking out some sadness
in the world a little bit maybe crave it
colbert a funny joke
where he talked about that woman that
went viral at the capitol where she
uh she was talking about how uh she's
like they maced me
this is the revolution they mace me and
he's like yeah guess what
uh they used to cut your head off
he basically said like you want to talk
to any other failed revolutionaries
you can't that was his whole joke oh wow
that's good
that's [ __ ] funny i thought i was
like that's that's heavy that's real
that's real uh yeah i know it's a good
point
we all think i think it gives us
significance and it adds some like
it's adds a little extra something to
our lives but
you know it's all [ __ ] man i think a
carlin i think of carlin
constantly i think that george carlin
like i wish he was alive
but i also think of like it's all
[ __ ] and it's bad for you that's
what i think yes
[ __ ] day on loop exactly
that's social media it's like it's all
[ __ ] and it's bad for you
right yeah well said georgie and and i
listened to one of his uh
special i think was back in town like i
don't know a month ago just popped it on
it is so angry i forgot how angry like
when i grew up i feel like
i listened to him like that's george
carlin but now everything's kind of kid
glovy
especially with a stand-up it feels like
that it felt so like
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] you can't
handle it you're a [ __ ] blow me kill
yourself
it felt so kind of just in your face and
it was refreshing
i do there's something about bill hicks
too that like i just i know
i hate when comics [ __ ] on bill hicks
because it's like dude the guy was such
a [ __ ] genius like i hate when
people are like first off he has like
five albums he died at 32 or 33 or
whatever
wow i mean right yeah it's insane dude i
mean
the guy was brilliant and like he'll be
remembered i
i some people like him for the wrong
reasons like calling a woman a [ __ ] or
doing a heck i'm like that was him at a
low point why are you yeah why is this
what's going
viral i mean i i love when he
i love when he's just silly like he has
that bit where he's like
my favorite thing to do here in colorado
he's doing a young community he's doing
that half hour special for hbo in
colorado
my favorite thing to do here in colorado
is watch smokers pass out because they
don't know when they're done exhaling
physically gifted comedian too i mean
bill yes
his silliness was so great i mean he
could get self-righteous at times but
i loved i loved them yeah his uh dog
that documentary on him was so good
because they he's he's like a chappelle
where he started at 14 or
15 whatever it was some crazy age and he
was a phenom like he was good he was
making fun of his teachers
and imagine being a 15 year old making
fun of your math teacher on a stage
killing like i got a couple zingers out
in class every now and then
i would get a big pop in the classroom
but imagine
being on stage and making jokes about
your class
that's amazing to me that's a great
point yeah he had it
so young and he had it in a way where he
was killing i mean to be killing for
adults at 15.
yes you got something man because
exactly
i think a lot of people like all right
but i feel like he had
that's why i guess what i'm saying like
he doesn't get credit for that gear
being able right so silly like he's not
killing with [ __ ]
ronald reagan jokes at 50 yeah he's
killing yeah
with silliness and i always remember
that rodney dangerfield special
you know for the young comedian special
in dangerfield intros and by going
this next comedian is so far ahead of
his time his parents haven't even met
yet
[Laughter]
man even the intro is a great line
that's crazy
yeah hicks has a special place in my
[ __ ] too because
he's got that look in his eye especially
in the later years where
he's in bum [ __ ] ohio nobody gets it
he's too smart for the room
he's this brilliant guy but they hate
him they want him to talk about his dick
and he's losing it and i know that
feeling so well well you're like holy i
got this bit about my anxiety and people
like shut up talk about clits you [ __ ]
you're like ah come on
this is something here hell yeah dude
it's so funny like
all things comedy i don't know if you
saw this they posted a story if you
haven't watched it watch it
it's on their instagram and it's about
bill hicks
and he's talking about hell giggs he's
doing an interview and he's like what
really gig ever and he goes i have a lot
of bad ones but i think this is my worst
one
and it's and it made me feel like such a
[ __ ] because we complain
but i mean we've never dealt with this
[ __ ] like i
i got a pint glass smash over my head
last year that kind of sucked
it's pretty good but
this dude was chased with guns oh wow
and he tells this story and it's like
these dudes were like this is like
deliverance
the gig yeah the story is telling i mean
it's so crazy just like these people
with guns are like we're going to kill
them
and they're chasing they can't get the
car to work and like break the window
for the car to open it
listen to the story because it makes i
mean like look
i understand gigs are getting easier and
safer and that's great and we've had
i think we've had a pretty charmed run
for the most part sure
every once in a while you think back at
a gig and you're like that was pretty
weird and then you hear that and you're
like
i ain't [ __ ] yeah no i mean uh
first of all i mean it obviously gets
better every decade like i read the marx
brothers book
and you know these are jews from
manhattan who would go out to the sticks
of like
arkansas to do some [ __ ] theater and
these guys are killers
but they'd murder in front all these
hillbillies and then the
the they get off stage they'll be in the
back back green room
and they're like hey where's our
paycheck and the uh you know the
hillbilly gotta be like get the hell out
of here you [ __ ] heebs or whatever
and they'd be like okay
and they had to run they had to run to
the train station
and pray to god they caught that last
train or they were stuck
in this [ __ ] [ __ ] town with a bunch
of anti-semites it's like in the heat of
the night
it's like in the heat of your eyes like
just get me out of here oh god get out
of here
oh my god [ __ ] i know crazy think about
it how about the larry miller story with
the the school
the school uh assembly what's that well
there's this
you've read have you read i killed yeah
yeah i read a long time ago i remember
i remember the ron white story very well
from there
hold on i want to hear that one after
but this this is a quick one so
uh larry miller it's i don't know 87
whatever
and some giant elementary school or high
school hires him to
to do an assembly like just do 20
minutes at the assembly
lift everybody's spirits and then we'll
go on to the whatever
and he's bombing and he goes jesus
christ like
but what would you what would you guys
like did somebody die in a fire before i
went on
and apparently the the whole fundraiser
was for a kid who died in a fire
and he was like the most beloved kid in
the class or whatever the hell
so they chase him out of the gym they're
literally
chasing him out of the gymnasium he's
running down the street he has to jump
in his car
like through the window uh starsky and
hutch style and
you're out of there they're chasing it
with pitchforks and [ __ ] he's like
looking behind him you know
so yeah that happened that'd be a great
gotham once i remember i opened a bit
where i was like man you ever drink
and uh do muscle relaxers at the same
time like it was leading into a bit and
it got stone cold silence and i was like
all right uh you know and then i get off
stage
and i was like what the hell happened
she goes this is a this is a benefit for
someone who died from drinking on pills
and i was like i should have looked at
the program
[Laughter]
wow so specific jesus no i know i
[ __ ]
i i got him back but like the first
seven or eight minutes i was like
i'm really bombing i shouldn't have
opened all this drinking on meds
material
i had a sibling but not i mean that is
you just like hit it uh bullseye i did a
joke about pedophilia
and like how it must be so easy to rape
a kid because they're kids and they're
weak
and apparently it was about the the
whole benefit was a handicap kids
so it kind of fit i love that you're
like i'm doing a benefit let me open it
with my child rape material
wow my defense it was a closer
i remember i did an atheist benefit once
and i
what i did atheist benefit uh friend
that's hilarious
yeah uh paul herzek who used to run a
club in new york in the 80s i made
friends with him
he watched me bomb for 15 minutes the
friars club and was like
i love your material no one else here
did but i did
uh he became buddies afterwards he ran
he ran stand up u
uh in the 80s in new york he's like he's
like susie essman was like the house
mc wow yeah it was like an 80s club and
we became buddies his son was uh one of
the managers at the stand
he's a great kid as well ryan oh and uh
okay anyway
um maybe with that ron white oh
like would tell the ron white story yeah
it was just a quick one but it was
basically
this critic just tore him apart again
and again
and ron white just sent him a note
with a razor blade and wrote all i said
was just in case you're ever in the mood
[Laughter]
that's great i love that boy that's
[ __ ]
and you hear it in his in his [ __ ]
perfect cadence
i know i was gonna say that's cutting
but it's great that he can go from a
tater salad to that you know that's a
comic
oh he's that album is one of the best
albums of all time
unreal public he's a [ __ ] beast
yeah he's that if you watch that it's on
youtube that's special
it looks like [ __ ] it's grainy it's
horribly shot he's sweating his ass off
but the comedy is so good that you don't
even care you're two minutes in you're
like i don't give a [ __ ] that this looks
like hell
he's another dude that is just i don't
know how you can't find him funny he's
kind of like
i remember he did a bit on that special
was about the whole bit was how he
cheated on his wife
and the crowd's applauding him it's like
he's so likable
he opens by being like my wife divorced
me because she got this crazy little
idea that i cheated on her in columbus
and i didn't i'll tell you why so
it's like the [ __ ] open with that bit
and this whole idea of this woman
inviting him back to his hotel room and
he goes and
this little guy popped up on my shoulder
and you know that guy is supposed to pop
up and remind you your past commitments
and moral fortitude well
didn't hear a peep out of that fella
see he's a dying thing with that that
charming [ __ ]
jim jeffries had that back in the day
where he'd kind of give me a wink and a
smile
you know but ron white is is the
ultimate uh
charm guy the southern accents the the
cigar the whiskey right here
you know the the full head of white hair
like just so
charming so likable yeah for sure man
it's so so so good i feel like we were
supposed to do recommendations but i
mean like i feel like we just gave how
many comedy recommendations
i know i know we'll throw some maybe we
should
slide out of comedy just for the layman
[ __ ]
well what do you got what are you
recommending this week i was gonna like
a show but it's a comedy show so maybe i
should switch it up i don't know
i'm gonna wreck a show too but it's kind
of comedy but i'm already embarrassed
about it
first season i watched the first season
of search party on hbo max and i loved
it
really i mean [ __ ] dude shout out to
john early who like
oh talent talent unbelievable
i think we talked about him on here did
we no we talked after with a pod we
mentioned
oh okay okay yeah dude he uh he's in
this movie with molly shannon where
she's dying of cancer who i i love molly
shannon from snow back in the day
oh yeah and she should have won an oscar
for this movie she's so good in it and
he was like the comic relief in the
movie
so i already knew him from shows back in
the day i always liked the guy but
he's a [ __ ] he's a star that guy he
is a star
i i said it to you before he officiated
schumer's wedding
and was killing from the altar just i
couldn't get out of that [ __ ] msg
show i was on
to go forever angry i missed that
wedding
that i mean that was unbelievable it was
in malibu it was on the beach it was
like right on a bluff
you know larry david is there uh apatow
seth meyers it was just
so cool damn dude i would have loved to
be in that jet with you too
oh it was great you know a fun story
about the jet i don't know if i'm
supposed to say this so
schumer was such a men she flew us all
out there she's like look i know you
guys have gigs or you're canceling work
or whatever so i'll fly you out on a jet
so you're
you're flying me out to go get drunk in
a malibu for free with larry david
you know no problem so
here's why schumer's cool she invited
all of us so it's like half the snl cast
me
marcus price bridget everett rachel
keith
and then all of her high school friends
from long island
so we're on a jet with all these
comedians and then these [ __ ] brassy
broads who
uh you know you know like they keep
money in their bra they're smoking
cigarettes
you know and they're like these long
island
queefs these coozes and uh they were
funnier than all the comics
i'm so pissed that i i remember trying
to get out of work and they were like
you can't
i had a sports show uh yeah i forever
i'm upset i wasn't at that wedding
i said i don't even normally look up the
wedding like i'm not yeah looking
forward to weddings but i knew that one
would be fun as hell
[ __ ] jet together getting loaded of
course she put us all up at a hotel it
was it was a great weekend but uh
another fun story from that wedding so i
rented a car because i was like i'm
gonna go to la after this and make a
make a whole week out of it podcast
whatever
so i rented a car so i drove to the
wedding and there was a long line of
cars trying to get into the wedding
obviously
so you got to go up wait your turn
finally get up to the guy with the
clipboard
he does a what's your name you go in
behind me true story
in the car behind me is a prius driving
it larry david
oh wow so i got to watch larry david
with
his daughter his hot daughter sitting in
shotgun
and i watch him in the rearview mirror
go up to the guy with the clipboard and
the guy's like so who are you and he's
like i'm larry david and the guy's like
i don't see it
i got to watch curb an episode
in my rearview mirror he was like what
what are you talking about he was like
doing a lot of this
i couldn't hear it but it was like i'm
on the left i'm blaring david what the
hell he's looking at his daughter and
she's like ah
geez you know and oh it was it was
amazing
jeff garland's behind him what the [ __ ]
richard lewis was like jesus christ yeah
i'm gonna start drinking again or
whatever but yeah just a
magical magical wedding so upset i miss
that
[ __ ] we could have used you i woke up in
somebody's apartment it was it was a
crazy night
uh so yeah my record search party
because i okay i love
i mean it's like a i love p.i stuff
i could give you a million noir
recommendations
i'm obsessed with yeah she's like kind
of obsessed with this
uh missing acquaintance i won't even say
friend and uh it's it's very very new
york very silly
okay uh and yeah john for me they're all
great but john early like i had me
i'm watching with ryan hamilton we're
both watching from our apartments and
like texting while we watch
and we're both like every time john
early speaks we're like
texting about because he kills us so
he's a killer uh
is that maybe from arrested development
fantastic
yeah okay yeah i'll check another one of
the if you don't like arrested
development like
so good three seasons are like [ __ ]
home run
i mean come on that's that's a huge uh
leg up for me and the lady when i met
the lady first off she was like i love
comedy and i was like oh here we go
whenever you meet a non-comic who loves
cow they're like
oh man eliza schlesinger
and uh you know whatever the hell movie
and you're like ah yeah great great
but she's like i love arrested
development i love 30 rock and i was
like oh my god this chick gets it
so that was nice [ __ ] still but
so good all right i'll give you my wreck
and uh
prepare to be embarrassed or i'm already
embarrassed for myself
but i i'm hooked i've already watched
the first two seasons in like two weeks
i'm on the third season it's a guilty
pleasure it's a
it's comfort food it's snack it's not
good for you i'm watching cobra kai god
damn it
is it good no it's horrible but i love
it
it's cheesy it's over the top but it's
tongue-in-cheek they know they're being
silly they know they're being horrible
damn everyone loves this show mark
maybe i gotta watch it is it that is it
feel good or what
it's feel good it's actually it's got
something for everybody that's the
beauty of it it's almost like game of
thrones like game of thrones is not my
cup of jizz i don't care about dragons
or fantasy or any of that [ __ ] but like
hey there's a love story hey there's a
fight scene hey there's a family drama
whatever
so this is like that where it's like
kind of a kid show kind of a comedy
kind of a action show and you got the
nostalgia factor
i always say kobrakai is like [ __ ] an
ex you know you're like this isn't good
but
it's familiar so i'll do it
so i i enjoy like if you want something
bubbly and light
put that on yeah i've heard people
love it i see so many people friends of
mine being like this show's
the most fun show like you know i was
never that big in a karate kid to be
honest
same same i just knew i was aware of it
and i like the augie
but the but i hear this show makes you
like william zabka
way way more completely they they it's
all from his point of view
and you're like i never thought of it
that way and then it kind of touches on
political stuff where you're like oh
it's a huge parallel with the democrats
and the republicans and that's
interesting so
oh well he's just like trans isn't real
you're a [ __ ] what the hell's vegan you
know so
it lets you see [ __ ] from that side and
it's it's
kind of that's well done you gotta write
show this is my new this is the new
shawl pitch
it's uh it's romeo and juliet but
they're the kids of uh
proud boys that's in antifa and they
commit suicide on instagram live that's
the whole show
and the father's like don't do it he's
just sleeping but that's that's right
and tibolt is he's like a huge tick-tock
guy
i had a similar idea romeo and juliet
but it's greta thundberg and barron
trump
and they they secretly want to are in
love but they gotta you know
represent their their demo and all that
yes
it's uh it does have to see i
i i should give it a shot i was in a cab
going to a uh one of those shows
and they did like a peacock ad for saved
by the bell the
the and it looks like it's very similar
to kobakai where it's like
very self-aware of how ridiculous it is
where they were like
uh the clip they showed was like but we
like we need to have a dance off and and
mario lopez is like
well i know how to dance and they're
just right short coach sure you know how
to dance
does that cheesy dance [ __ ] from like
the 80s or yeah
whatever and everyone like and they all
look at him like you think they're gonna
boo and they all just start applauding
and you're like all right this is as
i feel like it's first of all every
executive
is a puss and a wuss who's scared to
take a risk on something new so that
this nostalgia [ __ ] is is popping up
everywhere
it's fuller house yeah you can't miss so
i get it
it's money it's it's a it's a fish in a
barrel but
god i just hate that that's what it's
come to you know like art is dead when
we're redoing full house saved by the
bell and cobra kai
it's completely but you're watching it
so what can you see yeah
it works we've got to bring back family
matters now urkel is like a really
autistic adult
works in silicon valley he's like
[ __ ] dick
yeah exactly yeah so what else could
they remake like what's an 80s
or 90s show i'm trying to think of like
i bet nerds would go nuts for like
a remake of buffy the vampire slayer oh
yeah you know what they're redoing and
this is this is a fact is a
revenge of the nerds they're making a
show about it and somebody at a great
point they're like but the nerds are
running everything now
so it doesn't work and also revenge of
the bullies
the nerds were like everything they do
is like a [ __ ] law order svu subplot
where they're like
we put cameras in the girls dorms you're
like you can't do that anymore
yeah yeah also revenge of the nerds now
is just a school shooter
so it's a lot darker now before it was
like oh we're
you know we're putting [ __ ] in the
beakers now it's like i got an ak-47 in
homeroom
those movies got worse and worse like
one is great yeah it's great
two is solid we gotta we gotta avoid
barry sobel
in two three
three and four you're just like this is
i mean i watched them all as a kid i
[ __ ] loved the first one so much that
i was like
oh booger was great lamarr i loved it i
mean except for the
the oral rape at the end that we all
seem to get on board with
i mean where she liked it she was like
you were good in bed and he's like so
you're going to drop the charges she's
like absolutely yeah
yeah i came you're good lamar when they
when they start doing the techno show
[Music]
my mind was blown completely completely
and that was a young anthony edwards by
the way
who went on to er fame oh man he was
great robert carradine
the character yes [ __ ] dude oh yeah
we got uh david kung fu kill [ __ ] yes
we got keith in nashville oscar winning
song
i'm easy and uh
no but i i know of it i never saw it but
he's killed bill right
he no that's uh that's david keith is
nashville nashville
okay i think our boy ron on says it's
the best movie ever
what yeah well now i gotta watch it i
think it's a musical it's classic altman
where's a lot of like weird audio [ __ ]
but uh
it's brilliant it's okay it's and the
ending you're gonna be like
oh it's like network when you watch it
again you're like this is relevant
always ah all right
you're gonna love nashville i watched uh
with rogowski one night and uh
and we were both like whoa and the
music's incredible
okay all right i like altman it's like
there's like a country song guy who's
like
the whole thing is like he's a country
star and his whole song is like we must
be
doing something right the last 200
years it's all just celebrating america
it's great
oh boy that sounds timely i'll check
that out it rules
lilly time was like young and hot in it
and oh yeah
let me ask you let me ask you a weird
moral question
you mentioned revenge of the nerds with
the techno scene
and the dancing have you ever danced in
your life
i can't imagine you i can't imagine you
cutting a rug
anywhere really i have yeah for sure oh
really
i'll dance i'll dance tomorrow all right
if i've had a few of these i'll [ __ ]
i'll throw down
i respect that how about you i'll do it
i'm with you i can't do it but i will do
it
i'm terrible but i think women
appreciate the effort they're just like
he's terrible
but i'm glad he's trying exactly he's
not too cool for school where he's not
even
attempting it i'll look like a dweeb out
there and do the robot or whatever the
[ __ ]
but i feel like we have to kind of like
i'm so bad that i have to throw some
sense of irony in it like i'm i know i'm
bad guys yes
yes i'm not really i'm not you know
of course but yeah i'm not i'm not a
good dancer
same i i've almost thought i'm such a
bad dancer like i just can't get over
that hump
of like allowing myself to
enjoy it and like let go you know i'm
too like
i'm too much of a comic where i'm like
picturing everybody [ __ ] on me
we have that voice in our head
constantly being like you [ __ ] idiot
exactly you're an idiot you're a piece
of [ __ ] like don't you do that when
you're throwing on clothes to go out
yes right you're like we we've talked
about this a million times we're like
what's keith robinson going to say
about my exactly yeah i mean mine is
deep right but high school guy
all the dudes i went to high school with
all those [ __ ] mooks you know yeah uh
dude somebody gave me a leather jacket
it's like an 800 leather jacket
i can't wear it you could wear it it's
like a for like a headliner set you
can't wear that in new york you wear
that [ __ ] in the road
maybe maybe i just i put it on i even
put in my suitcase and i don't wear it
i know the feeling there's certain yeah
that's why i'm like it's not me but you
got to feel like you
i mean yeah yeah certain jackets like
they
may fit well and they might look cool
but it's just not you you know
i know but that doesn't mean it's a bad
i wear it like i'm like boxers at home
with the jacket on like looking in the
mirror
but i can't wear it out and and your
girl likes it
yeah she's like she says what you said
she's like if it's not you you can't do
it nothing
nothing hotter than a guy who's
comfortable and himself
you dress well who gives a [ __ ] i mean
like your [ __ ] your clothes fit and you
look i mean
come on who gives a [ __ ] you too you do
we're no phil hanley but
uh i mean yeah i think you got to be
comfy in it it's something you up
you up it a little bit on the road
because you know they bought tickets
right you know yeah a little bit for a
special but like if you're not feeling
it
i mean yeah i don't want to worry about
ruining a jacket while wearing it
so that too i mean yeah but if you're
not feeling it they can feel it
it's it's kind of funny how that works
but sometimes you throw a jacket on and
it just fits really well and you start
walking around and you're like yeah
maybe this is me you know
no better feeling when a jacket fits
great and you're comfortable with it ah
man you feel like you can take over the
world with a good jacket
uh you know i've been doing this thing
because i get on these youtube wormholes
and this is pretty cheesy but there's a
woman on youtube
marnie or something like that and all
she does is tell you all the secrets
that women
won't tell you and she's got all these
views because guys are like
we're curious we want to know you know
women everything's a secret women
because they they want that upper hand
and friend my friend does a similar
thing on her instagram and she's she's
good
at it she says [ __ ] i'm like okay i mean
it's an untapped market where every
single
single guy out there is going should i
wear this what should i say
you know what should i do what do women
like what do they not like you know and
we just have to do trial and error and
hopefully we get laid but she's actually
laying it all out and it's
[ __ ] amazing because you yeah i was
way off on everything
what were you give me one what were you
well she's like uh
talking about like what to wear she's
like nothing hotter than a guy in like a
good hoodie and i was like a hoodie
i thought that was like you know sport
wear or like loungewear around the house
so that was interesting that being i
think that's good because it's like
if it's if it fits i think they're just
kind of like oh he doesn't care but he
cares
right right yeah it's all like when a
woman walks into a
uh like your girlfriend walks into a
building or a restaurant
touch the lower back and like guide her
in [ __ ] like that where you're like man
i would have never known that
[ __ ] i was going too low that's a bummer
yeah so just little things where you're
like oh wow women
dig that i i would have never known that
and they don't they could just [ __ ]
tell us
but they don't women don't tell us they
want us to guess
i've been thinking about this a lot i
got a couple a couple bits about it but
i think
if they tell us we'll just do it and
they'll fall for us
and then we'll just move on so they like
end up getting hurt
they us it's like a puzzle if they just
told us how to solve it they're like who
gives it
i'm not a special puzzle you gotta work
to solve that [ __ ] puzzle dude
exactly exactly and it kind of means
more like if a guy just naturally does
the [ __ ] you like
you're like all right this guy was this
guy's met for me
that's good yeah it's up there they want
the work
they want us to like yeah i think it's a
whole thing about like women are kind of
programmed to be like soul mate let me
find my soul mate and you kind of
and i'm not saying like you know from
birth i'm saying that's how what they're
told as a kid that's what they're fed in
these movies and stuff
so they want the guy to guess it and if
you guess it that means like
he knows what i want yes together it's
natural
exactly exactly uh
but that's why i like that that
douchebag wrote the book what is that
like about nagging women
that bald guy dude i hate nagging so i
have a lot of people
about nagging i had a bit of i hate it
but women who are just like
they just [ __ ] on you and you're like
okay yeah anyone can do this it's not
yeah
yeah exactly like this isn't a turn-on
for me but
what was that book called it was like
the the hustler's guide to gash or
whatever the hell it was but
[Applause]
either way that book was like a best
seller because that's how
curious men are so after the show he's
like if you like the book i will sign
your gash
yeah bring that clam over here but
apparently that guy cleaned up
i mean yeah but that's a one that's a
one-trick pony isn't it sure
sure yeah he that was a one-hit wonder
but uh
hey it had it had a moment that guy had
a moment in the sun i think he got laid
yeah i don't know gotta think long game
though what uh
i agree give me uh any news stories you
got
yeah i got a couple zingers on some news
stories uh
one you see this thing in denmark
there's a new danish cartoon with the
world the man has the world's longest
penis
i did see that yeah so it's it's on some
like
you know pbs whatever the pbs is in uh
in denmark and my joke was oh i thought
that would be on the bbc oh
that's good it's more of a written joke
but you get it
that's good oh thanks yeah i saw that my
first thought was america
we're still number one i mean that's
embarrassing
but yeah that's great that's a great
joke the bbc one's so funny
um definitely embarrassing and i had
like eight jokes on the capital thing
but everybody's got that what well give
me a capital joke
uh well let's see uh hurry hold on i got
i gotta pull them i got so many
because you know you had a bunch too
yeah i heard the capital was gonna throw
up heat lamps for outdoor rioting
that's great uh oh one of my jokes was
uh
man it's a shame what happened at the
capitol they didn't even do temperature
checks
to let people in we're on the same
wavelength here
yeah yeah i picked my run i had one the
uh the capitals easier to get into than
the apple store
they made me do an appointment yeah
everyone had a [ __ ]
i mean that was insane it's like that's
like almost like it's sad that's almost
like prime twitter
i know i know you've heard of black
friday well that was white wednesday
uh the guy with the the guy with the fur
i was like if the police don't get him
peter will
uh oh and then my my other news story is
uh
kim kardashian divorced kanye
and i'm like man she freed another black
guy oh that's a [ __ ]
that's a big one yeah because of her
trump thing right that's [ __ ] smart
exactly also uh it's so funny that she
wants to be a lawyer
i know i know jesus christ she wants to
be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] lawyer yeah i mean she got a
couple guys out of jail so
i guess it's working i mean if you got
the power use it
for good that's true that is true
it's just funny how everybody in like
corporate america wants to be a
tick-tock star
and a famous person and social media
influencer
and everybody who's an influencer wants
to have a real job
yeah kanye wants to be president she
wants to be a lawyer maybe in four years
they both will be
and he'll get impeached and she'll be
[ __ ] she'll be dealing with the legal
stuff
yeah yeah she'll be the next you know
cochran or whatever
it's weird that also yeah that story is
[ __ ] crazy i'm trying to think what i
had
trump off uh it did laugh about i mean
obviously trump on twitter we gotta
weigh in on for a sec because it's
that's insane it's like
it's crazy that that is a bigger story
than him getting impeached
it affects him more than if melania left
him
yeah without question you're like i
built up like that is financially
[ __ ] him
hugely oh yeah oh yeah that was his big
platform
88 million followers and you're just
like
like if melania left him he'd be like
okay i bet yeah but if he's
he's like just do it quietly we'll work
out a deal twitter leaving him he's like
oh this is ruining my life right now
yeah i saw all the memes like he's
trying to get onto myspace hey
trump just trump has hit me on
friendster or whatever you know
he's gonna have an only fans jeff ross
he's gonna be only fans where he shows
his feet
yeah it's uh yeah it's [ __ ] weird uh
the story i saw was u.s representative
mary miller
i don't know if you saw this how she got
it was a pro-trump rally she wrote
hitler was right about one thing
and it was basically saying like the
youth is the future which is like
why why quote hitler a lot of people a
lot of people said that
you don't need to quote hitler yeah
it's like uh you know i don't like osama
bin laden but he did say that marriage
is everything
so i do like how he said that right
right
oh that's uh that's hilarious idea
what's that guy's name uh
a diamond hey do you mean yeah eating me
and he said uh milk does a body good you
know you can't forget that
ah if i had gotten the name damn it you
got it
all right how about a bed do you have a
bed for this week stalin said eat your
vegetables yeah that's that's hilarious
i didn't i didn't catch that lady crazy
all right this this actually happened to
me and i think there's something here
so let me run it by yes so doing some
gigs uh the other night and you know i
like to touch on
some touchy subjects and walk the line a
little bit and this
younger lady hit me up after in the
lobby and was like
i think it's so [ __ ] up how you
generalize like you you shouldn't poke
fun at the at a
just because it's a group you don't
generalize blah blah she kept saying
generalized and you're excluding and
discriminating against groups
she's like that's such a boomer move and
i'm like well isn't that
generalizing a group you're like you're
just doing it again
but somehow boomer is allowed that's
first of all that's a slur
and you're just you're just lumping this
group together well
you're doing it blur it's not a slurs
well not a slur but it's a it's a dig
i'm not putting boomer with the n-word
here but yeah
it's a dig yeah you're right she's
you're doing what you're claiming
to be against exactly but for some
reason you're
yeah i mean you're just completely
putting me in this box
of a group that you deemed as
inappropriate or whatever the [ __ ] but
you're still doing the thing that you
hate you're still generalizing
and you're accusing me of doing and
you're doing that's [ __ ] interesting
ah so she's
she it needs a comparison obviously yeah
she's
she's telling you that you're
[Music]
generalizing but she's calling you a
boomer is what like an old
it's like kind of an older person right
out of touch older guy yeah
and you're like well then technically i
should be allowed to generalize
right right like how come you can do it
but i can't it's interesting
mike kaplan used to have a heck campbell
had a funny joke about how he said uh
if you generalize i'm gonna i hate when
people generalize i'll kick your ass
like a
like an asian with karate or something
like that and i remember like oh that's
good
i butchered it but it's funny yeah yeah
like
um it's similar to that yeah it's like
you're you're uh generalizing but
you're calling me someone who
generalizes so then i guess i'm all
right
you know right yeah the thing you're
calling me out for doing
you're doing in front of me to me
what's like the opposite of a boomer
i guess so gently or millennial
millennial
yeah yeah it's almost like what
was there a bit that she called you out
for doing that with
i was doing some some racial bit some
bit about like
black people in police or something like
that and
it's not even an offensive bit it's just
about black people so you could she was
just jumping on it
oh it's about how we we can't say master
bedroom anymore and i'm like well if we
can't say the term master bedroom
we got to stop saying masturbation which
i think is worse because you're beating
something defenseless
[Applause]
so it's like the point is you can tie
anything to
something offensive or something uh you
know
inappropriate yeah she just sounds
really dumb i mean like
it's like uh you're just generalizing i
was like no it's making a joke
it's not even like maybe maybe it's this
he's got a gun shoot him you know
something like that like you're doing
the thing
that i'm you you're mad at me you're
doing it to me
you're you're a hypocrite you're you're
just generalizing boomer and you're like
well you're just whining
white lady or something like right oh
yeah yeah
that's not it but it's like but i like
where your head is i don't want to go
with like the karen sugar that's so
[ __ ] hacky and easy but like there's
something about like
uh there's something about the like well
being a white woman and complaining
after a show
you're not breaking new ground either
aha
there it is yes then she has to see the
manager
i wouldn't say karen in the joke no no i
won't sing
she has to see the manager and you're
like wow you're revolutionary
yeah yeah i hate to generalize i hate to
generalize but uh i've seen a lot of
white women do this before too
right right that's good all right
we cracked it i'm gonna try that one
next week
boom we [ __ ] got it all right bloomer
um
boom all right i had this idea about
like
so i was talking to someone who told me
he's battling depression and i was like
yeah i've never
uh battled depression in my life uh
every time depression comes on i'm
always like uh
you win
this round you know like depression is
not a battle depression's like getting
jumped by five
guys and you're like just take what you
want and oh
and they're like i want your entire day
and you're like it's yours
and you're like same time tomorrow oh
that's great that's great
and then the only way you can reason
with the guys is you're like look
let's all get drunk together you know
like something where
you you deal with the depression by
getting drunk or taking a pill or
something
yeah you're just like [ __ ] all right
i'll stay in bed all right you got this
don't move right that's a great analogy
like the
jumping instead of battling because a
battle you can win
you know we we won the battle we lost
the war whatever they say
so uh you can you have a chance of
winning if depression comes on you're
like
there goes the weekend exactly that's
good
yeah battle you can win yeah it's a a
battle you can't it's
it's not a it's not a battle you can win
battles
right or or maybe this could be a tag is
uh
although the only reason it's like a
battle is i i do have a battle cry
you know something with depression and
crying battling all right i'm reaching
no there's no battle where you're like
i'm just gonna watch season four the
sopranos again yeah battles in the dirt
with bloodshed and machetes and pistols
and flags you know
this is uh pajamas and ice cream
and netflix i got enough to take with
i'm gonna try that this week for sure
and uh
let's tell people make sure to email us
if you're
because we're gonna start a patreon soon
so you can sign up for that soon but we
have an email uh
one more drink with mark and sam
gmail.com
nice one more drink uh spelled out not
the number
one more drink with mark and sam
gmail.com
send us you know pet peeves
recommendations
a joke anything we talk about in the
show whatever
yeah questions uh we'll do a little ask
me anything a joke idea maybe we can
bounce it around uh and we'll do that in
the patreon so you send us a question
check the patreon and we'll probably
answer it or talk about this
on all platforms apple all that [ __ ]
spotify
uh whatever and subscribe make sure you
leave a review
i'm having a ton of fun doing this man
this is yes i'm loving this so i hope
i hope the people are liking this too uh
same i hope i hope everybody's having a
drink with us at home and uh
yeah tell a friend spread the love share
it
uh yeah so we'll keep it going every
week
we'll see at the bar see you at the bar
cheers